[Musique ambiance "suspens"]
Salut.  Souvent sur Twitter, vous me tagguez
sur des liens vers des sites ou des vidéos.
Et très récemment l'un d'entre vous
m'a envoyé un truc qui s'appelle
"13 trucs psychologiques
qui te rendront la vie plus facile"
Je me suis dit que ça valait le coup de les lire
de les analyser et de les commenter avec vous.
Générique !
[Musique Générique]
Il y a 13 espèces de "vérités"
qui sont mises sur cet article
Je vais les détailler une par une,
puis vous donner mon avis dessus.
Merci à la personne qui m'a envoyé le Tweet.
Et si vous ne me suivez pas sur Twitter,
vous avez le lien est dans la description.
Et Twitter c'est pas mal pour
garder le contact ensemble.
[Mitigé] Oui...
Pourquoi pas.
Mais ça voudrait dire que cette personne
est aussi dans une démarche d'analyse
et de manipulation positive pour essayer de te plaire
Et puis j'y crois qu'à moitié quoi...
Comment  ça se passe si mon mot clé c'est courgette ?
Va falloir que j'utilise courgette
toutes les deux secondes ?
Je pense qu'à chaque fois que
j'utiliserai courgette,
je plairais beaucoup moins
à la personne...
Alors c'est même plus large que ça
C'est ce qu'on appelle le "Story Telling"
qui est très utilisé, par exemple, en marketing
et dans d'autres techniques d'influence.
Effectivement on est est beaucoup plus
touché par une histoire personnelle
que par une statistique ou un fait avéré
ou un discours prononcé de manière
un petit peu universitaire...
Le Story Telling c'est l'expérience,
c'est les émotions
Et effectivement, ça marche
beaucoup plus pour convaincre.
Ben euh...
Non.
[Riant] C'est pas vrai.
On n'en sait rien !
Je pense que ça c'est mis
complètement au hasard...
J'ai fait une vidéo sur le
Pierre/Feuille/Ciseaux
Elle, est basée sur des études qui ont été faites,
et je vous invite à regarder la vidéo
que je vous mets là, quelque part...
Mais là, comme ça, d'instinct,
je dirais : Non.
[Pouffant de rire]  Pourquoi ?
Et puis je me vois mal,
à chaque fois avant de jouer,
poser une question.
Ça va se voir un petit peu...
C'est pas faux !
Qu'est-ce que t'as pas compris?
C'est pas faux, parce qu'il y a
une sorte de mimétisme en fait.
Et le fait de faire un mouvement
de "oui" soi-même,
influence,
toute proportion gardée,
le côté vrai de la réponse
qu'il faut donner.
C'est une sorte de réponse sociale
en fait,
Si l'un dit "oui",
moi aussi je vais dire "oui" ;
S'il pense "non",
je vais répondre "non".
Non
C'est pas mon rêve premier...
Alors ça, c'est vrai.
Dans les endroits fréquentés,
les gens se checkent
inconsciemment le regard de l'autre,
pour s'éviter, etc...
Mais ça, c'est normal.
De là à dire qu'il suffit de regarder
bien droit devant soi
et de tracer...
Je vais essayer ça, à la station
de métro à côté de chez moi...
Je ne suis pas persuadé que ça donne
"Moïse et la mer rouge" non plus...
Alor, ça c'est vrai.
Notre cerveau est programmé pour
mieux mémoriser une tâche inachevée
ou interrompue,
qu'une tâche achevée.
Là c'est une petite mise en situation
rigolote qu'il vous propose, mais
dans le fond, c'est vrai.
Si vous allez jusqu'au bout
de la tâche,
c'est à dire jusqu'à chanter la chanson
en entier ou l'écouter en la chantant en entier,
vous aurez plus de facilité
à vous en débarrasser.
Je trouve chelou cette question.
Tu veux vraiment que tes enfants
mangent du brocoli, mec ?
Oui, c'est une petite technique
de manipulation.
On avait vu ça aussi, sur la chaîne,
l'année dernière,
dans les techniques de manipulation.
Donner l'impression que la décision
leur appartient au départ.
Donc, pour ça, on pose
des faits établis.
Le fait établi c'est
qu'ils vont manger des brocolis.
Mais, par contre, c'est eux
qui ont le pouvoir !
Ils ont le pouvoir
de choisir combien.
Et en les concentrant là-dessus,
sur ce sentiment de liberté là,
et bien, on ba leur imposer
quelque chose.
C'est assez marrant la manière dont ils
abordent ces points là, mais
dans le fond,
ça aussi c'est vrai.
Pourquoi c'est vrai ?
Bé je vais vous le dire pourquoi...
Ça s'appelle l’écho-kinésie du baillement.
Dans notre cerveau, il y a quelque chose
qu'on appelle les neurones miroirs.
Comme leur nom l'indique,
ces neurones là, réagissent
à ce qu'ils voient.
Ce sont ces neurones là qui nous
permettent d'apprendre des choses
par mimétisme.
Et qui nous permettent aussi
l'empathie.
De détecter que quelqu'un n'est pas bien...
et nous aussi on se sent pas bien...
Maintenant, pour ce qui est de l'espionnage,
c'est un petit peu exégéré parce que
il suffit que la personne vous ait dans
son champ de vision
pour que les neurones miroirs
fassent leur travail
et que la personne baille aussi.
Je ne suis pas certain qu'on apprenne
ça dans les services secrets...
C'est, ni plus, ni moins, un détournement
d'attention psychologique
en fait, on n'est pas concentré sur ça,
sur cette action là,
on est pris par une conversation
on accepte le truc.
Boon... oui c'est vrai...
En partie !
Ça ne marchera sûrement pas à 100%,
mais bon... en général, si tu demandes
à un pote de t'aider, il te dit oui aussi...
Oui
Ça paraît logique.
Next !
Alors oui, ça, tout à fait !
Je ne vais pas développer, parce que ça aussi
je l'ai déjà développé sur la chaîne,
dans une vidéo qui s'appelle :
"Aborder une personne pour la première fois."
Et l'idée de cette vidéo ce n'était
pas forcément en séduction...
Oui. Alors, pas focément
parce que ça peut aussi mettre
une grande alerte
et préparer la personne
à un refus.
Je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ce point.
Ouais, alors c'est un raccourci là !
C'est vraiment pfffuiittt !
L'idée principale, je pense,
qu'ils ont voulu mettre derrière ça,
en tout cas, j'espère que c'est ça,
c'est de vouloir créer des
interactions simples
non engageantes,
avec une personne tierce
qui a du mal avec vous.
Et c'est vrai que ça aide à passer
les premiers aprioris,
et si on arrive, comme ça,
à créer des interactions simples,
on va commencer à créer
un début de complicité.
Un tout petit début.
Mais ça permettra d'aller plus loin.
Il était plutôt bien fait
ce petit article.
N'hésitez pas ! Continuez à me tagguer
dans des trucs, sur twitter,
que vous voulez me faire partager.
Je passe toujours voir.
N'oubliez pas de noter que ce dimanche 23,
on fait le live sur la chaîne à 17h30 !
Je sais, c'est le jour des élections.
Mais justement, à 17h30, en attendant
les résultats, ça changera les idées de tout le monde.
Donc : Save the Date !
Concernant le concours-énigmes
pour gagner ce que vous savez...
Si vous ne savez pas, c'est toujours
expmiqué dans cette vidéo...
Il y a encore un indice dans cette vidéo
pour prendre de l'avance.
"Mais Fabien, à quoi ça sert tous ces indices d'énigmes
qu'on a avant la vidéo en question ? "
Comme je viens de vous le dire,
ça vous servira à prendre  de l'avance
le jour où va sortir la vidéo
concours-énigmes.
Et croyez moi : de l'avance,
il va vous en falloir...
Dans cette vidéo se cache
une phrase entière !
Une phrase clé.
Pour la trouver, il faudrait
en montrer plus quoi...
Tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que le premier
mot de cette phrase commence à l'alternance.
A très bientôt dans le futur !
Ciao !
[Musique générique de fin]